akshay brought four boxes of chocolate
truffles to a party each box contains
six truffles
every guest at the party ate exactly
three truffles and there were none left
over
how many guests must there been at the
party must have attended the party so
we're trying to figure out how many
guests how many guests must have
attended the party so we let's actually
let's actually define a letter to
represent that so let's say that p
or let's say g
g for guests
let's say the g is equal to the number
of
guests at the party
then we could actually set up a relation
between the number of guests the number
of truffles each guest ate and then the
total number of chocolates so what was
the total number of chocolates that we
have at this party well he bought four
boxes and each box contains six truffles
so the total number of chocolates at the
party must have been four
times six
four
times six truffles must have been the
total number of truffles at the party
so let me write this down this is the
number
of truffles
total
number of truffles total now what's
another way of thinking about the total
number of truffles at the party well you
have g guests so you have g guests
and each guest ate three truffles each
guest ate three truffles so g times
three is also going to be the number of
truffles at the party
number of truffles
total
number of truffles total so these two
things need to be equal to each other so
we could figure out what 4 times 6 is
and then we should say well 4 times 6 is
going to be some number and g times 3
has to equal that same number what must
g be so let's think about that step by
step so let's just visualize 4 times 6.
so
here is one box of truffles we get six
truffles so it's one times six
two times six
three times six
and four times six or another way of
thinking about four times six that's the
same thing as 6 plus
6 plus 6 plus 6 which is 6 12
18 24. so what we have here on the left
hand side is 24. so we get
24
and now we know that this is going to be
equal to the number of guests at the
party this is going to be equal to the
number of guests at the party times 3
times 3. so what times 3 is equal to 24.
another way of viewing this
another way of viewing this is if g
times 3 is equal to 24 that means that
24
24 divided by 3
divided by 3
must be equal to g
must be equal to
g
so one way of thinking about it if i
were to divide these truffles these 24
truffles into groups of three three for
each guess well the number of groups i'm
going to have will tell me the number of
guests i have so let's do that
so let's divide it into groups of three
so let's see here is one group of three
right over here one group of three
and now i have another group of three so
two groups of three
now i have three groups of three
three groups of three here's four groups
of three
here is
five groups of three
six groups of three
seven groups of three and eight groups
of three so if i were to take 24 things
and divide it into groups of three i get
eight groups so we see
we see that g
let me get my pen tool
we see that g
or i could say 24 divided by three is
eight which must be equal to the number
of guests of the party the other way of
thinking about it is i'm like hey some
mystery number here g that i'm trying to
figure out the number of guests at the
party times 3 is equal to 24. so what
times 3 is 24 well you could just think
about all the multiples of 3.
3 times 1 is 3 3 times 2 is 6 3 times 3
is 9
12
15
18 21
24 that's 3 times 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8. 3
times 8 is 24 so g must be equal to 8 or
8 must be equal to g or we had exactly
eight guests at our party